hey welcome to our roundup of all the
call back secrets Easter eggs and
references and Avengers endgame and it's
all spoiler free no wait
reverse that actually this entire video
is just one big spoiler if someone you
know hasn't seen endgame sending them
this video might actually kill them
don't do it
endgame is the culmination of over a
decade of MCU films so as you'd probably
expect
it's loaded with callbacks to earlier
films a big chunk of the movie is
actually set within previous Marvel
movies thanks to the wonders of time
travel and game returns us to three
classic MCU locations from other films
at the exact same time those prior
events were taking place and the Russo
brothers thoughtfully reassemble those
old ensemble casts to make it happen
that was nice of them right so we go
back to 2012 New York as it appeared in
the original The Avengers 2013 Asgard as
it was originally featured in Thor the
dark world and 2014 Planet Morag just as
it looked in the original guardians of
the galaxy we also stopped by New
Jersey's camp Lehi in the year 1970 when
it was serving as a shield base this
place is hugely significant in MCU
history it's the military base where
Steve Rogers trained prior to receiving
dr. Erskine super serum and it's the
location of the secret bunker where
Black Widow and cap discovered the
preserved brain of Hydra scientist
Arnim Zola during Winter Soldier I am
not recording but no single Marvel movie
gets more endgame love than the one that
really started the whole phenomenon 2008
Iron Man end game opens with an
emaciated Tony in a black tank top
trapped and scared for his life which is
also how we found him during his
Afghanistan captivity in the original
movie happy tells Tony's daughter Morgan
about her dad's love of cheeseburgers
which is also an Iron Man callback that
was the first item that Tony requested
after being freed from his terrorist
captors for cheeseburger first that
proof Tony Stark has a heart arc reactor
collectible which now rests upon a
commemorative wreath was a
yep that pepper gave him in the first
movie of course
Tony's big closing line before he
defeats Thanos recalls the final words
he speaks in his first movie I am Iron
Man
finally endgame is the first MCU movie
without a mid or post credit sequence as
the final Marvel studio logo comes up
just before the lights come on we hear a
familiar clang on the soundtrack it's
the sound of Tony fashioning his first
Iron Man mask still stuck in an Afghan
cave but Tony's not the only Avenger
feeling a bit misty and nostalgic for
bygone times almost every character in
the film has some kind of wink or nod to
their personal back stories as they zip
through space Clint tells Natasha that
they're a long way from Budapest
this was their infamous and still
mysterious joint shield mission that the
duo first discussed during the Battle of
New York and the first Avengers what
happened in Budapest is this the setup
for the coming Black Widow spin-off
adventure just before she sacrifices
herself on Vermeer to obtain the soul
stone
Natasha tells Clint that she refuses to
judge him based on his worst actions
because you didn't this is a way back
call back to the first Avengers team-up
film that was when we found out that
Clint has been sent by shield to
assassinate Natasha a notorious KGB
agent but ultimately ended up recruiting
her an entire scene pivots around a
potential close-up fight with Captain
America and an elevator which was the
setup for an extremely memorable scene
in Winter Soldier before we get started
does anyone want to get out many of the
same characters overlap in both
sequences that was by the way the first
Marvel film for endgame directors Joe
and Anthony Russo so naturally it
deserved a little love note that during
the elevator scene in order to get
Loki's sceptre away from Jasper Sitwell
cap leans in and says hail Hydra
this is not only a clever ploy as future
cap already knows that Sitwell is a
double agent but a sly reference to
Captain America comics and a
controversial 2017 storyline
cap has false memories implanted in his
head that made him believe he'd been
recruited by Hydra years before during
his fight with his double Avengers 1
Captain America said he could do this
all day that's what a much younger and
frailer Steve said to a bully who was
beating him up in an alley in First
Avenger he also referenced this line
when fighting Ironman in civil war when
all the backup previously dusted
Avengers show up for the big fight
Falcon announces their arrival by saying
on your left this was of course what
Steve used to annoy him while they were
jogging through Washington DC in Winter
Soldier simpler times God cap and Bucky
also referenced their memorable pre-war
parting banter from First Avenger before
cap leaves for a final time jump he
tells Bucky don't do anything stupid
until I get back how can I taking all
the stupid with you and then of course
cap finally gets to say his big line
Avengers Assemble this got teased at the
end of Avengers age of Ultron but the
movie cut off before he could actually
say the words
Avengers by the way anyone else noticed
that wasp calls him cap in this movie
she made fun of Scott for doing that
very same thing back in ant-man and the
wasp cap it's that's what we call him
also little fun detail the new Asgard
community has been constructed in the
town of tongs burg Norway this was where
Odin Thor and Loki had their final chat
in Thor Ragnarok Odin instructed his
sons to remember this place and called
it home this film had so many callbacks
in fact that both the opening and
closing song serve as references the
film opens on the Benatar with Tony and
nebula listening to the 1967 traffic
song dear mr. fantasy the lyrics of
course have some relevance to the movie
it's asking for an entertaining hero to
come along and bring everyone out of
this gloom just like Tony in the movie
but it's also notable for dating back
much earlier than most of star Lords
music collection that we've heard that's
because in Guardian
- he got his hands on a Microsoft Zune
with over 300 songs
dear mr. fantasy must have been among
them the film ends with the 1940 staple
it's been a long long time this tune was
previously featured in Winter Soldier
when Nick Fury visited Steve in his
apartment it also has some somatic
relevance I mean for Steve it really has
been a long long time he's been waiting
for that dance longer than we've been
waiting for this movie
lots of cameos and riffs on pop culture
to pick apart an endgame as well
including the first ever character to
debut on a Marvel TV show and then later
make it into an MCU film that
distinction goes to James D'Arcy who
portrayed Howard Starks driver at when
Jarvis on TVs agent Carter and shows up
in this film's 1970 sequence in the same
role this Jarvis of course inspired the
name of Tony Stark's computerized Jarvis
who then later inspired the creation of
an Android who was not named Jarvis
but vision who's still dead try to keep
up anyone catch that lone young man
standing by himself at Tony Stark's
funeral that was actor ty Simpkins as
Harley keener the ten-year-old tennessee
kid who helped Tony out in Iron Man 3
not rear itch ERDs a guy next to me at
the theater thought it might be Reed
Richards sorry - co director Joe Russo
has done cameos in all of his MCU movies
and this one's no different he was the
guy at the support group early on who
poured out his heart about his recent
date to Steve the late great Marvel
legend Stan Lee had his customary cameo
as an employee 1970s New Jersey motorist
rumor has it that this is the second to
last appearance and he'll make his final
cameo in this summer's spider-man far
from home we'll miss you Generalissimo
finally we got not one but two cameos
from the sitcom community ken Jeong and
Yvette Nicole Brown both showed up as
security guards finally the film
referenced a lot of previous time-travel
movies including Bill & Ted's Excellent
Adventure
whoa but not more frequent that back to
the future to the movies actually share
a few things in common they're both
concerned with the creation of a dark
dystopian alternate timeline and they
both feature memorable scenes where
characters time-travel then hide and
observe their past selves ant-man makes
the connection official though when he
instructs his fellow Avengers not to bet
on any sporting events this is Biff
tannins evil plan that creates an
alternate crime ridden hill valley also
fun fact composer Alan Silvestri worked
on the scores for both the Back to the
Future series and Avengers endgame
that's the power of love
[Music]
most of these MCU films are riddled with
riffs and references back to the comics
but this time around we're wrapping
things up so they kept it a bit lighter
Bruce's new professor Hulk persona comes
straight out of the books where he
occasionally decided that the best
solution is to merge his two
personalities into one new being just as
in the film the professor or merged Hulk
has a relatively normal looking head
that resembles Bruce Banner but a huge
green Hulk body notably as Bruce
engineered this version of the Hulk to
return to his human form when he gets
too angry this is the weakest form of
the Hulk
during the 1970s shield sequence we
briefly visit Hank PIMs office where he
still got the original old-school
ant-man helmet on his desk still working
out the kinks I guess it doesn't seem
super practical also Tony's daughter
Morgan Stark borrows her name from a
comics character the original Morgan
Stark was Tony's evil cousin who was
constantly scheming to get Stark
Industries away from him in infinity war
Tony told pepper he had a dream about
having a child who had been named after
peppers crazy uncle Morgan we named him
after your eccentric Uncle Bob what was
the name words so they swapped families
but the name is the same and the
craziness also in Tokyo we see Clint
battling a Yakuza named Akihiko this
character faced off against Nick Fury
and Marvel Comics it's entirely possible
that these movies are building to some
kind of variation on the comic-book team
The Young Avengers we've got several
possible candidates already in the mix
early on Clint trains his daughter in
archery and even uses the nickname
Hawkeye to refer to her and Young
Avengers comics Hawkeye jr. is named
Kate Bishop but it's possible the movies
may be going another way with it i
wonderful learn more about Hawkeye jr.
and Hawkeye's upcoming Disney Plus
series plus Scott's daughter Cassie Lang
has grown up a bit and appears to be
nearing potential superhero age in the
comics she becomes the hero stature and
later stinger
through the use of Pym particle
technology bear in mind the comic book
Young Avengers also feature a hero named
kid Loki who is just low-key trapped in
the body of a young boy following a
resurrection related accident
please Marvel put this in a movie
and speaking of Loki in one of the films
past timelines we see him grab a loose
tesseract and take off with it into a
portal to parts unknown now the heroes
end up getting around this by going back
even further in time and swiping an
older version of the tesseract
but do we definitely know what happened
to the version of Loki who escaped seems
like he could really do some damage
unstuck in time and armed with a space
stone is this the setup for the Disney
Plus series we're also left with a
possibility at the end of this film that
Thor is going to be fighting alongside
the guardians for the time being is it
possible he might be joining the team
full-time will Hemsworth appear in
guardians 3 or will he be needed back on
earth where the new Captain America is
just a normal man with a jetpack and
what happened to past timeline Gamora
that quill can't seem to find did she
return to her own timeline or is she off
having an adventure of her own and let's
talk about Peter Parker's high school a
closing shot reveals that his pal Ned
apparently was also snapped and thus
will still attend high school with Peter
actually the far from home trailer seems
to indicate that Peters entire high
school class including MJ and Flash
Thompson are all still in high school
after the five-year time jump so they
all got snapped together that was
convenient finally I want to draw your
attention to the fact that Steve Rogers
ends the film as an old man wearing a
wedding ring the clear assumption is
that after going back in time Steve
hooked back up with Peggy Carter and
they built a life together but we
learned in Winter Soldier when Steve
visited an elderly Peggy Carter that she
had gotten married to someone else and
started a family did Steve ruin this
guy's entire life or and I don't want to
blow your minds here was the other guy
actually Steve all along and Peggy just
couldn't say anything
time travel okay that is a ton of
information and I really want to go see
this movie again so let's wrap it up
here if you found amazing incredible
endgame references that we missed hit us
up below and let us hear about it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]